this video released by colombia's army
shows soldiers carrying on a stretcher
angel padilla romero better known by his
alias fabian he was one of the top
military commanders of the eln or
national liberation army the largest
standing rebel group in colombia
he was captured on monday after being
injured in a military bombing 10 days
ago in the northwest of the country he
died in a hospital in the city of kalyan
tuesday
after 10 days of searching by landon
river as evidenced by the work carried
out by our security forces he was
located yesterday wounded covered with
bushes and vegetation
it was very close to the place where the
aerial operation took place last week
fabian was the leader of the eln's
western warfront in the region of choco
one of the group's strongholds and one
of the country's most wanted men
he was the alleged mastermind of many
murders and kidnappings and responsible
for the displacement of thousands of
people
despite some respite brought by the 2016
peace deal between colombia's government
and farc rebels the country has seen a
surge in violence
the ireland dissident factions of the
farc and remaining paramilitary groups
are fighting for control of remote areas
and profitable illegal mining and drug
trafficking
fabian's killing is a success for the
right-wing government of president ivan
duque a critic of the accord who had
promised to improve security something
that has proven elusive
fabian was the most important leader of
the eln in colombian territory it is a
decisive blow to this criminal structure
fabian's arrest validates the impeccable
work that colombia's heroes carry out
every day and we will not rest until we
dismantle all these criminal networks
the eln was founded in the 1960s as a
leftist rebel group inspired by the
cuban revolution with 2300 combatants
and an extensive support network in
cities it continues to routinely attack
soldiers and oil pipelines especially
close to the border with venezuela where
most of its commanders are believed to
be hiding
attempts at peace negotiations with the
group have so far failed
the death of fabian is a major blow to
the organization but not the last stroke
alessandra
al jazeera